le personnel de ce supermarché à
guyancourt s'affairent dans les rayons
des l'annoncent d'un reconfirme ans
mercredi soir le lendemain jeudi
beaucoup de personnes sont venues faire
quelques stocks les premières nécessités
l'huile la farine le papier toilette le
sopalin enfin tout ce genre de produit
donc oui on a vu un afflux des clients
sur ce genre de produit
certains certaines familles de ces
produits comme l'huile on a fait + 60 %
sur la journée d'hier c'est des chiffres
qui sont totalement irrationnel il a
fallu ce vendredi matin réapprovisionner
les rayons de farine de pâtes de sucre
ou de papier toilette
mais ce super marché avait anticipé
cette affluence ils sont désormais mieux
préparé on commande aussi le colis
supplémentaires on va commander aussi
sur les ponts des rues et sur les gros
volumes on va commander sur du
conditionnement plus gros que d'habitude
on va passer du carton à la demie
palettes et de la palette et de la nuit
palette à la palette pour deux faces
certains enfants sont là dans tous les
cas il faut qu'on ait de la marchandise
ne faut surtout pas concret nous mêmes
effets de panique
pas de panique en tout cas ce vendredi
matin les clients avaient des petits
chariots la plupart ne souhaite pas
consommer plus que d'habitude je vais
continuer à acheter au fur et à mesure
en fonction des besoins
mais je vais pas en fait me ruer sur les
rayons et tous les idées et il faut
aller c'est aussi pour les autres donc
on vit au jour le jour si vous voulez
donc avoir un paquet supplémentaire mais
pas plus quoi c'est vrai on a envie de
le faire tous nos courses d'un coup dans
le sens où l'attestation faut la créer
pour sortir pour aller faire les courses
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya cette envie de
faire les courses mais comme je le fais
pour le mois généralement avec leur
confinement les supermarchés devraient
voir quand même leur chiffre d'affaires
augmenter durant le dernier confinement
les ventes en france ont été supérieures
de 10% à la moyenne